et pour maxime chaix journaliste
essayiste et fondateur de dit news media
il est important de penser à la détresse
de millions de familles libanaises
moi j'aimerais recentrer le débat sur la
population sur les populations du levant
qui ont subi depuis neuf ans une guerre
absolument atroce avec des centaines de
milliers de morts et le liban accueilli
notamment entre 1 et 1 million et demi
de réfugiés sur une population de 5
millions demi d'habitants
mais quand on parle de punir des pays
ont puni les populations avant tout
parce que les élites politiques
elles ont des ressources financières
allant des alliés sont dans des systèmes
financiers complexes qui leur permettent
d'échapper à ces sanctions
moi je pense à la population libanaise à
la population syrienne et ça représente
des millions de personnes qui subissent
aujourd'hui par un cataclysme économique
avec un effondrement du niveau 10 me de
du niveau de vie pardon un
renchérissement des denrées alimentaires
des biens de première nécessité et une
crise économique sans fin qui engendre
des pénuries d'énergie qui engendre un
manque cruel d'opportunités d'emploi et
d'avenir